last May the NFL owners announced a
policy requiring their players to either
stand for the national anthem or remain
in the locker room during the anthem
anyone kneeling or protesting would be
fined but what a difference a few months
make as the NFL has now announced that
it won't implement its own new policy so
this weekend Kenny Stills and Albert
will some of the Miami Dolphins
took a knee during the anthem of their
season opener their teammate Robert
Quinn stood but he did so with his fist
in the air so what penalties will they
face none an NFL spokesman tells Sports
Illustrated the status quo continues as
productive discussions are ongoing on
the important work of social justice now
you might have forgotten that this all
started back during the Obama era in
about August 2016 that was when Colin
Kaepernick refused to stand in a
preseason game for the 49ers after that
game he defended his gesture saying I'm
not going to stand up to show pride in a
flag for a country that oppresses black
people and people of color to me this is
bigger than football there are bodies in
the street and people getting paid leave
and getting away with murder well
remember Kaepernick basically started on
police brutality but now this is morphed
in doing much broader movement that the
NFL felt that it had to support so in an
attempt to appease the protesting
players and put the kibosh on the
protest the league committed nearly a
hundred million dollars earlier this
year to what they call social justice
initiatives but just where does that
money go well seventy three million
dollars of it will be divided into three
organizations 25% to the United Negro
College Fund 25% to Dream core which is
kind of a left-wing social justice group
founded and led by Van Jones their goal
is to lower the prison population by
half and provide sanctuary to all not
what that means and then half of the 73
million dollars will go to something
called the players coalition now the
players coalition was a non-profit
quickly formed by a group of NFL players
to guide the social justice conversation
and receive any money that the NFL might
be willing to donate and get this
they've consulted with George Soros
backed criminal justice groups and the
liberal Center for American Progress
this according to ESPN the Coalition is
led by 12 players but it was founded by
Malcolm Jenkins of the Eagles and
retired player and Quan Bouldin the
group advocates for everything from
criminal justice reform to racial
equality to voting rights but some
players have withdrawn from the group
including michael thomas and eric reid
who was one of the first players to
protest right along with Kaepernick in
an interview with slate Reid trashed the
NFL's attempt at hush money but he
called it basically called it and
resigned from the players coalition
altogether claiming that Malcolm Jenkins
told him the money would come from funds
that are already allocated to breast
cancer awareness and salute to service
so it would really be no skin off the
owners backs they would just move the
money from those programs to this one we
didn't agree with that because we
weren't trying to cut other worthy
programs well whatever the case the NFL
thought it could buy its way out of any
further controversy surrounding the
anthem by basically paying off a
patchwork of left-leaning groups but it
didn't completely work on the broadcast
side of this issue the increasingly
liberal ESPN has decided it was simply
no longer air the playing of the
star-spangled banner at all before
Monday Night Football well I hope Colin
and company are happy with that the fans
aren't viewership of the NFL season
opener at least was down 13% from last
year and reached the lowest rating for
an opening game since
2009 they did better yesterday though
well I have a better idea of all this if
these players or the NFL were truly
concerned about making life better for
minorities in the United States why not
consider dropping the political chip on
your shoulder and consider working with
the Trump administration I know you
might not like his tweets I get that but
I have a question are you aware of
president Trump's openness to criminal
justice reform working together we can
restore the rule of law keep dangerous
criminals off our streets and help
former inmates get a second chance at
life and a second chance that many of
them will really succeed it if only
given the chance America is a nation
that believes in the power of redemption
or his willingness to commute the
sentences of those with exemplary
records and unusual circumstances like
Alice Marie Johnson my message to
President Trump is thank you so much
President Trump for taking the time to
really look at my case and to really
look at me and as I've said before I
will I promise you president Trump I
will make you proud I love that moment
and of course president Trump's policies
have made this the best time ever
for black Americans to find jobs black
unemployment is at a stunning and record
low currently at six point three or six
point five percent although the
president disagrees with the anthem
nailers and we all know that he also
offered them an olive branch back in
June you should stand for our National
Anthem you shouldn't go in a locker room
when our national anthem is play I am
going to ask for all of those people to
recommend to me because that's what
they're protesting people that they
think were unfairly treated by the
justices and I understand that and I'm
going to ask them to recommend to me
people that were unfairly treated
friends of their
for people that they know about and I'm
going to take a look at those
applications and if I find and my
committee finds if they're unfairly
treated then we will harden them or at
least let them out so my question is how
many of the NFL players have taken him
up on that offer reached out to the
president well maybe some of yous back
channels I don't know but to not do so
confirms the suspicion that the anthem
protests are more about ideology than
equality and that would be a real shame
and that's the angle